who wins here and as it starts to like
filter into society
one interesting thing that we're seeing
is that people are becoming
full-time digital artists and there's a
market
where there's collectors and curators
and
you know people who want to support
those artists maybe the prices are a
little bit inflated right now
but certainly like there's there's a
market where um
you know you you you want to donate or
or contribute to
a creator that you really like and and
you can
you know pay maybe 50 cents to two
dollars but there's enough of those
people that
an artist can make a living on that and
if you compare that to the model of
instagram
right very different model on instagram
you're
uploading content but you're you know
monetizing it through
facebook's proprietary ad platform and
oftentimes you're just not getting paid
at all
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to yang speak special
limited series
every thursday bringing to you a deep
dive on a topic that affects our future
and this week we are talking about the
future of nfts
non-fungible tokens and if you've heard
of nfts
you're probably like me or you've heard
all these people talking about it and
you have no idea what it is so the goal
of this episode
is to understand what the heck an nft is
and should i care about it and i think
the answer that question is yes you
should care about it it is
fascinating and i want you guys to get
on this train
sooner rather than later because i
believe
from what i've learned that it will
start slowly but eventually change
everything now i brought on co-founder
and ceo of an organization called
openc and they are like the ebay or
amazon
for nfts non-fungible tokens so you can
pretty much sell anything that's an nft
on their site it's going great for them
um it's growing like a weed
so it's a fascinating conversation it's
timely right now people are selling
nfts for millions of dollars we talk
about that
and i want to learn how the common human
can apply them to their real life so
that's what we talked about
it is timely it is interesting and it
will be relevant for everyone at some
point
so tune in right now devin finzer
ceo co-founder of openc the nft
marketplace joins
yang speaks the future of nfts right now
[Music]
all right welcome back to yang speaks
today
we are talking about the future of
blockchain the future
of nfts with um a pretty remarkable
entrepreneur cutting edge has been
seeing what's about what's coming around
the bend
for a lot longer than most of us as we
now talk about nfts
you've been doing this for years now so
devin finzer the co-founder of
openc which is a marketplace for
blockchain based digital
assets devin welcome welcome to the show
man
thanks so much for having me i'm pumped
i honestly i have been and i've been
telling people
you think these nfts are cool yeah i've
got a guy coming on um i've been saying
you've been the guy you've been the guy
coming on
for a couple a week and a half now
so um how the hell did you get into nfts
um and let's just explain for
our audience to what an nft is
um from let's call it an expert's
definition
sure sure um yeah i can start with kind
of the definition of an nfc real quick
so
um an nft is a digital
object that you own in kind of a brand
new way and
in a way that's similar to a physical
object is one way to think about it so
when you own a physical thing you can
kind of do whatever you want with that
thing because
you have kind of the property rights
over it right so you could go
and throw it in the trash if you didn't
want it anymore you could give it to a
friend
across the world you could go and put it
for sale on ebay or craigslist you sort
of have that freedom to do
to do whatever you so desire with that
with that object
um digital or nfts are sort of the
equivalent in the digital world
where they're these digital assets but
you have the same
property rights over them so you can for
example sell them on a variety of
different marketplaces you could take
them into different applications you can
kind of
move them around without relying on a
single application so to
contrast that with traditional digital
asset
if you think about like an item inside
of a video game
well you can kind of use that item
inside of the game
maybe the game kind of lets you move it
to another player maybe not
but you can't necessarily go and you
know sell that on
ebay very easily so i get the zelda
sword or the ocarina of time which is
maybe i'm dating myself i can't take
that to another video game i probably
can't even take that to another zelda
maybe i could
but in this instance in nft i could
actually
get that object and take it to another
video game yeah
exactly or you could go and put it for
sale on a marketplace
and then before people could copy that
too right like if someone could design
that ocarina
of maybe this is a horrible example
people have never played this video but
someone could design that sword
hack a video game and throw it in there
too and it wouldn't be the same right
and they're they're not hackable right
it's completely unique to you
yeah exactly yeah they have there's this
third party
sort of neutral record called blockchain
that says here's where this item
originated from
here's all of the different places it's
been
right who's owned it this is its full
history over time
um and this is the only one of this this
item that ever
has existed right so some people have
compared it to art
but i think that like doesn't do it
justice in a sense that
you could broaden it to cult like art so
you have to be an art expert
right dude today in like real modern art
right or not like historical art
renaissance or whatever it is um you
need an expert but there's
collectibles so people like a wayne
gretzky rookie card
or xyz athlete like that would require
an expert to validate
it but also if you had a wooden desk
from
george washington's home when he was a
child whatever it was like someone be
able to verify that too this is
similar to this would an nft could
technically cover all of those
types of things am i getting that right
totally yeah no so
nfts are very generic they can represent
all sorts of things now
what's been interesting is that nfts are
starting to
be applied to both existing markets
gaming is actually is a huge industry
right people spend
billions of dollars buying things inside
of fortnite
but it's also opening up new markets and
that's where digital art comes into play
digital art is not has not traditionally
really been a market right because you
to your point you can always
copy and paste that image and then send
it around so there's no real
there was no real concept of owning a
piece of digital art
this technology introduces that and it's
unlocked an
entirely new and very weird and
interesting market where
you know if if uh i'm sure you followed
the recent news with these really giant
69 million dollar digital art sales
that's not something that has ever
really existed right um and so that's
what's exciting about the technology is
it's so generic that it's both
unlocking new markets and then it's also
changing the game for
uh existing markets as well i mean there
are some crazy
um valuations like i've seen a flying
pop-tarts rainbow cat
is getting about 600 grand i've seen
a month old digital artwork selling for
69 million dollars what is making these
things valuable in the short run right
like that's where the height let's start
there like what is
what the hell are people paying for
right now yeah i mean i think it depends
on
on the scenario right so i uh
i guess let's look at an example right
so um
one example is a project called crypto
punks uh
have you ever heard of that one by any
chance okay so
sure so crypto punks um was
uh launched in late 2017
and it was actually the first nft before
people even had come up with the term
nft
but basically it was 10 000
very simple images of these
these punks um they sort of had these
unique characteristics they were like
kind of you know ones that had
sunglasses other ones had
were alien punks or zombie punks only 10
000 of them and
you know as per as with what we talked
about with the blockchain
there will only ever be ten thousand
crypto punks
that is you know as long as the
blockchain continues to function in the
way that it has for many years now
that's you know that's sort of a known
quantum these punks are like little
faces
right they're like little little faces
um
it looks pretty cool yeah they're kind
of cool pretty simple
so you know back then they were given
out for free so people could just go and
claim them on the blockchain
and it actually took a while for them
all to be claimed
and then they started you know as as you
can do with these things you can trade
them around so
every once in a while someone would buy
one for you know 50 bucks 100 bucks
something like that
um and then fast forward um
fast forward to today and
these you know they're the first right
they're the first
nft um holding one is indicative of
being extremely early and passionate
about
the nft space and you know just a few
weeks ago
uh crypto punk sold for eight million
dollars um
and and so these these items have become
sort of the first instance in my opinion
of the first digital antique um where
you know it has this real cultural
value to it you know people um people in
the deep crypto community maybe maybe
outside of the deep crypt
people are still sort of starting to get
interested but um
you know people will put them as their
twitter handle there's this association
with uh owning a cryptocurrency either
you're really wealthy and you bought one
on
a secondary market or
so yeah i think that's how that's an
example of how
these things can sort of accumulate
cultural
value over time and really in
interesting ways that people don't
typically associate with digital things
um but you know it's not much different
than owning you know
a really historic piece of art that was
created in the
i don't know 17 1800s or something like
that right
um so it's starting to emerge and people
are starting to kind of
get used to it but it's definitely
something that takes a little bit of
wrapping your head around
right so i'm going to dive into this a
lot but before if if anyone's coming
into this not knowing
like not understanding big why the hell
would someone pay
you know this much money for a digital
face or something
just as absurd as it sounds and i don't
understand it let's not judge because
people are paying
millions of dollars for which you some
could argue objectively
either ugly paintings or in terms of
modern art stuff that a child could do
um now i understand art is different but
art is art like people pay what they
want to pay now
let's but before we get there let's back
up a little bit
because to me
i'm fascinated by how people got into
this because
um before now because now i understand
where it's like all right rainbow cat's
kicking butt where i can make money or
this is like you know fortune magazines
writing
headline articles and cover pieces on it
but for you
you're a an entrepreneur um i believe
your your background
or the senior had something called
credit karma i was like like help build
that
um and now your next step
after like a credit score company was
successful you're like
nfts like this not these sort of like
tech tokens is where you went tell us
how the hell you got into this man well
like a lot of people i fell down the rip
the crypto rabbit hole and in 2017
tons of people were starting to think
and talk about
crypto um and you know if you're
interested in sort of the future of the
internet and the future of technology i
actually think crypto is
is one of those frontier areas that is
going to be
just continue to be really really
interesting and really
you know transformative over uh you know
it's already starting to be
transformative but just increasingly so
over the next
couple decades um and so at some point
for me i i realized i wanted to
be in crypto i wanted to devote my
career to that and it was a question of
what did i want to do um and in
particular
i had always been more interested in um
you know things that people could
use in their everyday that that
mainstream regular people
could use in their regular lives
who are clueless and we're going to come
on casually to a website and interesting
right yeah exactly and then crypto at
the time there wasn't much
like that it was it was primarily
sort of deep financial or sort of
speculative
use cases around icos initial coin
offerings at the time was a big thing
um and then there was there was a lot of
like early um
there's a lot of deep technology being
built up because it you know it is
still the infrastructural phase for for
crypto certainly
um but there was this really interesting
phenomenon
going on with the project called
cryptokitties which was
actually i guess technically maybe the
second nft depends what you
count as as first or there were some
things before that
cryptokitties launched and they
basically
you know they went out and created this
simple
digital cat game right where you could
buy and sell cryptokitties
and it was just really fun it was sort
of the first time that people got to use
a crypto application
um that wasn't you know just purely
financial it was something that you
could kind of like
play with in a much more fun way also i
also
kind of was exposed to just how
interesting the gaming ecosystem had
gotten right games have become
really the social networks of the future
there are
places where people are spending a lot
of time with their friends
their big economies it is exactly the
intersection of those different uh
industries gaming crypto consumer
um was just really exciting to me and
then in terms of
um openc in particular so for context
openc is a
marketplace for nfts so we allow you to
buy
and sell any nft um uh
through a variety of mechanisms openc is
what your ceo of now you founded this
right
that's how long ago yeah we founded it
in late 2017.
okay and your vision then i think it was
then or at least what you're saying now
you want this be the amazon or ebay
for nfts or digital assets is that
correct
yep that's right so how does it work i
can go on the site and i can just buy
stuff like i would on amazon that is
forms of digital art or assets or things
like that
yeah that's right yeah so you can go and
you can buy
uh nfts on openc you can also explore
any nft
because all of this data is public
on the blockchain you can go and browse
and you know
you can find that uh neon cat that you
that you were talking about or that
people are work um we index
or we uh store all the data in our our
own
replicated in our own server so it's
easy easily queryable by regular
folks and then if you want to resell it
you can do that as well
and can i buy do i have to buy them with
crypto or can i buy them with dollars
like how does this work
at the moment um you do have to use
crypto we do have some
um support for being able to purchase
more easily purchase crypto uh
through widget on our site but it's only
available in certain locales
but we are working on better integration
of credit card support as well
[Music]
this episode of yang speaks is brought
to you by hello tushy
yes we're still doing bidet
ads on this podcast and there's no other
bidet you want to talk about
than hello tushy you cut down on toilet
paper which adds up by the way if you
have to if you're an adult you're buying
your own toilet paper that stuff adds up
it also clogs your toilet so you have to
worry about that
it's better for the environment and some
people particularly myself they love
them it's easier
it's better so the brand new 3.0 hello
tushy
modern bidet is awesome it's
eco-friendly it's stylish easy to
install and it cleans itself it's pretty
freaking cool
all water so here's the deal get your
booty in gear folks get a bidet
go to hellotushy.com yang to get 10
off plus free shipping we love doing
these because there's discounts so 10
off
and free shipping pretty great special
offer just for yang speaks listeners go
to hellotushy.com
yang for 10 off hellotushy.com
[Music]
yang
some of these things you can like print
out print in like these digital frames
and i want to put one behind us
there's a pokemon card that's called
musky dodge but it's elon musk's head on
rafiki holding up simba but simba is
dodgecoin
that's just the tip of the iceberg right
like there's a lot
more to where this can go yeah well i
mean
you can think about a lot of different
markets that this applies to
um one we could start with is the
creator economy right there's
um experiences like patreon which are
awesome where you can
contribute to a creator that that you're
excited about but you don't you don't
necessarily get um
anything in return right you don't get
sort of a slice of
um their you know their creations or
you know you're not really owning
something at the end of the day you're
just contributing which is
great but imagine if you could
contribute what if you could buy
you know this is the case today right
you can buy a piece of digital art um
for one of your uh favorite you know a
collectible from your favorite musician
or you could you could buy something
from a non-profit that you're trying to
support
and sort of have more ownership in that
project or that person
um and not in like an investment sense
but just in a way that you know you
you now have this uh object on the
blockchain that you can kind of show
off and and say that you know i was a
supporter of this
person very early on so as an example
um there's an artist who came on to
openc
uh maybe a couple years ago named josie
bellini who's
basically a crypto artist right a lot of
her art is
crypto themed but she's really built up
a name for herself
and she's been able to monetize by just
selling her digital art to her
her fans and she does a really good job
of it she she's very
you know she always has a very limited
supply of art she doesn't inflate it
she's very loyal to her collectors
and and her collectors have been able to
support her by purchasing the art and
then some people
are able to resell it uh down the road
and so there's this nice symbiosis
between
the people who want to support uh
creators or organizations and
um and and having some stake
in their uh success as well so that can
apply to all sorts of things right
um uh we've had a good number of uh
charity auctions on openc recently we
did uh
the uh i don't know if you saw the snl
skit
on nfts but um snl actually tokenized
that
skit as an nft um and then
auctioned it off and i believe it sold
for around 350 000
and then that was given to a charity um
to to help against with with uh
anti-asian
um hate crimes i think there's an
infamous like prince
underground uh like after party with
like all the celebrities in the world
and they filmed some of it but i imagine
like if you had filmed that whole thing
like someone to own it
um now do we have to own everything in
society maybe maybe not but like the
fact that there could be some value
there and used for potential good
is fascinating to me um and this is one
so i was listening to
there's a guy named scott galloway who
was on the pivot podcast but he has his
own show called the prof g show one of
the things he says is like and he's
older than me and he's like
he's like i don't know something about
my brains what he said is that it's
tough to wrap your head around this
where like a 10 year old like just gets
this instantly
because of how they're wired and for us
for people that haven't grown up with
this
it's like more steps and more steps but
i'm curious um
like mechanically how this works so
let's say we're going to do nfts for
andrew yang like the yang gang
and you could buy a token that made you
a card-carrying member
of the yang gang andrew would get money
for his cause or for charity or for his
campaign theoretically or whatever
and then you as a yang gang nft like
token holder
could i don't know use that token could
give you access to
ask me any things or q a sessions with
andrew or access to specific
virtual or in-person events and you just
have to have the token id
to get in and then you could sell it
theoretically to others um
if that value became higher or i guess
lower at any time is that a good example
of how this could work yeah
one very cool but two like what does
this blow up like what
who wins from this who loses from this
because i
see and scout with some of this he's
like i see the
middle men and like the middle brokers
getting
crushed here because i'm going directly
to
andrew yang in this case or i'm going
directly to uh
snl um there's no agent there's no
insurance like what
um what are the good what who wins here
and as it starts to like filter into
society
yeah it's a good question and i don't
know if anyone uh yeah it's really hard
to say
um i think um you know
my sense is that this is a brand new
market
um and it's going in my opinion it'll be
a very
big market um as we've sort of alluded
to this is not just about
collectibles and it's not even just
about art it's about really the
tokenization of
all sorts of things right and beyond
gaming
but into physical assets real estate you
know all of these things will
in my opinion become um tokenizing
watching it's just kind of a question of
when
um in that world i do think that um
there's a lot of benefits will accrue to
to users right so
and and people will be able to monetize
things in a way that they uh hadn't been
able to before so
what one interesting thing that we're
seeing is that people are becoming
full-time digital artists and there's a
market where
there's collectors and curators and you
know people who want to support those
artists
maybe the prices are a little bit
inflated right now um but certainly like
there's there's a market where um you
know
you you you want to donate or or
contribute to
a creator that you really like and and
you can
you know pay maybe 50 cents to two
dollars but there's enough of those
people that
an artist can make a living on that and
if you compare that to the model of
instagram
right very different models on instagram
you're
uploading content but you're you know
monetizing it through facebook's
proprietary ad
platform and oftentimes you're just not
getting paid at all right and so the
the economic models of what people in
crypto call the
the web 2 ecosystem which is basically
the the
internet as it's evolved um to be
dominated by a couple of large
very large players um has not actually
been a very economically efficient um
the the business models of that world
are very indirect and and benefit those
large organizations and often
you know they do they have allowed um
you know
you know i'm a huge fan of of all of the
internet properties that have
or most of the internet properties that
have been created youtube google these
are
all great things for users but they they
have not
achieved sort of the vision of a true
digital economy where lots of people are
being able
are able to participate in significant
ways
so what i see happening is this really
giving birth
to just a you know a giant new economy
um that distributes values to all sorts
of participants so i think i do think
that
um you know new companies like our
ourselves are going to be built
from that in inside of that world
um uh folks you know across
lots of different industries and you
know probably even the existing
incumbents like the instagrams and
facebooks the world are
going to get involved at some point as
well um
but you know i just see it as sort of
the the birth of a
of a brand new model um and
and really the the sky being the limit
in terms of um what sorts of things
people can build
the more you dive down this rabbit hole
the more you realize how game-changing
it is and it's frankly mind-blowing
to think about okay right now on
instagram
i post something i'm an influencer i
post something
i get a bunch of likes and then maybe
people will pay me
to put products on there meanwhile
facebook gets all the real money which
they're getting your data
um and we did a whole episode my first
episode of future of was with e-commerce
experts
and they're talking about yeah it's
better for people to start new
businesses now and like small business
owners can
have a global market through facebook
but the real winner there is facebook
and the bigger it gets
the more harder it is to do well as an
e-commerce
salesperson a better facebook um really
dominates but you're talking about a
world where people can
they don't need facebook as much in the
sense that they can buy a piece of
xyz piece of a company piece of real
estate and buy and sell it on their own
future and like so where it's getting
what i'm curious is like let's say
you're a young
you're 17 years old and uh you get into
harvard you get into mit you get one of
the best schools in the country
instead of having to take on debt um
to go to school you could actually sell
your equity
and you could sell a stake in you
whether it's your future income or you
could put an llc around it um
or just your i mean you have to figure
this how this works but your future
worth in a way and i mean i know like
sports companies have tried to do this
with like the like draft prospects and
things like that but there's
um a way where someone could finance
their education this way
based on their future prospects thoughts
on that like how it values
people or how the like the weirdest [ __ ]
you could buy like an nft
of like and then could you sell that an
open c your platform i don't know
yeah i mean i think that yeah those are
all interesting ideas and
yeah i don't i'm not claiming that you
know everyone is gonna kind of sell
you know equity in themselves uh maybe
you know people have experimented with
that but i
um you know i think it'll start more
with
you know things like um you know digital
art
games these things where people you can
buy something and then
you can become sort of a participant in
that economy and become
much more entrepreneurial in that
economy so actually let's take gaming as
an example right so
gaming um worlds are these very
sophisticated
economies right um billion dollar
economies in some cases
but they're completely controlled by the
game developer their command cult
control economies there's no imports
there's no exports there's no free trade
there's some entrepreneurship but it
often gets shut down
so what would happen if you kind of
opened up that economy to all of the
free market activities that we know
may make economies a lot larger right so
what if you um allowed items to be
traded on external marketplaces what if
you allowed um
items inside of the game to be used
inside other games
what if you allowed um people to take
loans out on items or
um you know really participate and own
pieces of the economy in a way that you
traditionally can't um in online games
well there's examples of
these starting to emerge there's a
couple projects in the nft
space um one is called the central land
the other call
is called cryptovoxels where you own a
piece of land in this virtual world
and then you can build things on top of
it um and
the these plots of land and in one of
those
um games in particular uh used to sell
for maybe
i don't know 50 or 60 uh dollars
each um people bought bought the land
started building out a little world
themselves um
now people you know we've seen land
bundles of land sell for hundreds of
thousands of dollars
as this as this world starts to get more
and more interesting
and people are creating virtual museums
where they'll put up their
nfts from various art projects so sort
of the beginning of
um you know what people have talked
about with a some sort of metaverse um
type scenario it starts merging what's
fake fake
quote-unquote failure what's digital and
what's real in terms of physical
our generation has been like our parents
generation was able to
and we all well frustrated we're like
why don't you take your money you have
it invest in real estate or invest in
some
xy and invest it and the reality is our
generation doesn't have any money
and if we um the little money we do have
is not enough to invest in real estate
or
um things with like you know
high upside the way it was for our
parents and our grandparents certain
ways
and this is the closest thing i've seen
for us to actually have real investment
opportunities
um in the sense that
you could buy small pieces of real
estate that have tremendous upside but
you don't have to put up a million bucks
for the down payment or a hundred
thousand dollars whatever it is you
could buy it for a smaller piece
and to your point what's defined as real
estate has now broadened very
differently so a little piece of land
in a growing video game wow sounds fake
more and more people gonna play that
video game more more people can invest
in that video game and play so that
appeals to real estate
if you own it is actually as valuable or
more valuable than some real estate in
real life
um so that's what's wild to me
or this like it is essentially a
democratization
of let's call investments in a weird way
i hesitate to
call like and i don't think all nfts
should be viewed as
an investment right um some of them are
just useful in some capacity right
you could have um nft event tickets
right where you're just
buying something to attend an event
right but it certainly broadens the
landscape of what can be um
owned in a digital context right and and
so when you
when you when you introduce at the end
of the day what nfts do is they
introduce property rights
on the internet and the implications of
that are just
extremely broad
[Music]
this episode of yang speaks is brought
to you by helix sleep
what i love about helix sleep is that
you can get yourself a mattress
for not just yourself or whoever your
partner is wherever you're sharing the
bed with whether it's pets or kids or
partners
you can find the right mattress for you
so helix sweep has a quiz that takes
just two minutes to complete
matches your body type and sleep
preferences to find the perfect
mattress for you so if you like a softer
firm or you sleep on your side or your
back or your stomach or you see hot
you can do a whole bunch of things with
helix so i took the quiz
i got the lux model i got the biggest
one i could find and it's
the right kind of softness and i love it
so here's the deal just go to
helixsleep.com take their two minute
sleep quiz and they'll match you with a
customized mattress that'll give you the
best sleep of your life
and i mean that best leave your life
sleep like a baby helix right now
is offering 200 off all mattress orders
and two free pillows
for our yang speak listeners at
helixsleep.comyang that's helix
h-e-l-i-x-sleep.com
for up to 200 off and two free pillows
[Music]
if i want to start buying
tokens um how do i start
there's a variety of ways that you can
get started um
there are some websites that allow you
to buy directly with the credit card
my personal recommendation would be to
uh
get a crypto wallet um there's one
called metamask which is the
the most unpopular crypto wallet um
and then if you want to sort of
experience these in their
full glory you will need to buy crypto
um and uh you know you can do that on a
variety of places coinbase is
you know big one in the us um and then
you can transfer that crypto
to your metamask wallet and what's
really cool about that
is that now you own your crypto
um it's it's literally in your wallet
and that's the same place where you can
own your nfts now you got them in your
wallet
and you can go and use a variety of nft
experiences with that same wallet
so let's say you go and buy
this project i was talking about called
the central land which is a
virtual world project you can actually
buy a
clothing inside of that virtual world
and sort of fashion items you can go and
buy that in openc
and you can have it in your wallet and
then you can
connect your wallet to decentraland and
use your stuff inside of decentralized
and the interesting thing about having a
crypto wall is it kind of goes with you
wherever you are on the internet i
see that every every time i talk to some
folks like you i see the potential of
this i see where it's going it's
remarkable
the one thing to me that seems a massive
barrier
for this to really become mainstream
outside of like the gamer
expert techie community and maybe we all
become that way that's true but
the big barrier to me is the cost of the
barrier entry
in the sense that um anecdotally or just
as a comparison
mobile payments are better than paying
on a credit card
for even convenience right like if i
could just take my phone
and tap it on something or hold it up or
screen it's faster it's easier it's more
efficient it's theoretically
theoretically more
secure than credit card payments yet the
united states as a country has not moved
even though the tech is there from
credit cards to mobile payments
why because the the cost
of like getting rid of your credit cards
and moving them on your phone is not
worth
like the net benefit of just starting to
use your phone however in china
who is paying cash all the time they've
moved to like 90 i don't know actual
number but
the vast vast majority people in in
china use mobile payments because they
never had credit cards
so my point is the analogy i'm using is
crypto is going to be better more
efficient theoretically more secure
changing everything but there is a major
cost
to getting into this you have to
basically get a
your own token you have to save it on
your own usb drive you have to protect
it
and if you lose that token
it's gone it's gone forever or someone
else can steal it if someone else has it
that sort of thing
what do you say to um
how what are your thoughts on how the
barriers to getting into this
get lower now people told me told me
coinbase is
like a version of the kind of bank that
if you lose your token you can get it
back i don't know
um but what like how does this get
easier for
for my mom to get into this market
yeah no it's a great point um i actually
think one of the interesting things
uh you're framing was interesting in
that you said like crypto is better in
all of these ways
i actually think it's kind of funny like
crypto is worse in all these ways right
like
uh it's harder to use it's the if you
look at
the technical side of the ethereum
blockchain it's really slow it's
expensive
and what's kind of funny about it is
that people are still
using it right and so i think that's
actually indicative of the opportunity
is that if you look at things where like
look at the early internet right where
you had to um install special hardware
on your
machine you had to you know it's really
slow you had to
like get a web browser people you know
were at some point in their lives they
didn't know what a web browser was they
had to figure all that stuff out
similar to a wallet today right um so
there's
and yet people did it because there was
cool stuff on the internet right there
was fun
stuff to explore so similar i think it's
a similar situation where
people are uh using nfts because there's
cool
you know there's cool things to be done
right and in the case of nfts there's
you know sometimes it's financially
motivated sometimes it's motivated by an
experience around an nft but
there's lots of different reasons but i
do think to answer your question i
i do think that the barriers need to
come down
and they're gradually coming down if you
look at where we were
three years ago we're in a very
different world today
where wallets work you know while it's
barely even worked back then
um you had to you couldn't there was
nothing you could really download in
your browser
that would connect you to ethereum was
actually this separate
desktop application so a lot of people
don't remember this because
back then it was it was really just like
you know people who uh were very into
crypto
uh who did this and so there's not that
comparison um you know it feels it feels
really hard today
um but we've we've come a long way and i
think we'll just
keep on making progress on really all of
those
areas right credit card onboarding is a
is you know starting to become a little
bit better for crypto
um wallet infrastructure is becoming a
bit easier to use
so then fast forward you know i would
say maybe in the next couple of years
the experience looks you know a
step function from where it is today and
maybe someone who's
more casual and doesn't know about it
can get
can get into it a lot more easily
essentially the
the pioneers in this crypto space saying
we're not worried about this because
it's so early that innovation will
happen like the hardest innovation is
where this tech is working and the
different applications of it but it will
become more mainstream and to me
i say maybe i think it's my opinion like
maybe like
you'd even argue like the pc the
personal computer
was getting better and getting better
and even blackberry was kicking butt but
it took oh like once in a generation
entrepreneur steve jobs to like
fundamentally make this appealing to the
masses um
and you could argue henry ford was a
similar type whereas like we had the car
we had it for a while
um but it was that the concept of
mass adoption or mass production for him
and then about you know
making it more palatable but maybe you
know that's this
like you're saying and you're probably
right that look we're still in like the
pcs the size of a garage inside of a
like you know
building um stage of crypto right we're
still really early
um which is exciting especially when you
think about the game changing
abilities of this you know what's the
future of your site starting to look
like
what is what is exciting you about what
openc is going to be
able to do and what role does it play as
nfts start to become more normalized
i think the vision of our um
of openc has always been around the
broad expansion of nfts as
a um as a phenomenon in the world
and opencv being a portal into that
world
where people can come on explore
discover
uh search and purchase and sell
nfts and so our focus is really around
how do we be the best place for people
to do that
and how do we focus on what our
customers are excited about what our
customers want
and so a big piece of that going forward
is exactly what we've been talking about
right it's
reducing the friction um for the first
for people to
to use nfts and right now it's not too
hard to go and
and discover nfts but if you actually go
and try to buy an nft
yeah it definitely does require uh
getting a little bit deeper into the
tech
and uh understanding how wallets work so
we do want to
reduce those barriers quite a lot um and
then the other
um thing that we're really focused on
is um how do we expand the use cases
uh for nfts right today it's primarily
around
um pretty expensive digital art and one
of the reasons for that
is the blockchain that these
assets are living on is actually if you
dig into the technical side
it's quite expensive to move things
around so one of the things we're
working on is
better more scalable technology that
will
allow people to move things around at
higher frequencies
and support a much broader range of
prices
so you know one of the reasons that art
in in nft world sells for tens of
thousand
thousand dollars is because there's a 50
transaction fee typically
that you're paying to the to the miners
on the blockchain
um and if we can reduce that transaction
fee
then we could have you know people
buying things for
10 cents 50 cents yeah and that's worth
it unless it's
high enough exactly right yeah for five
you know
five bucks because or under 50 bucks it
doesn't not worth it i believe you guys
just raised 23 million dollars in your
series a
um so congratulations i believe
open c is a version of our future
um and it's uh it's super exciting so
c s e a o p e n s e a dot io
is your website um devil put your
twitter handle and such in here but um
i appreciate your time thanks for
pioneering a space that none of us
have fully understood yet um but i think
we all will be
going forward so thank you for coming on
and teaching i learned a lot
um the reality is we don't really know
that's why i take away here is we have
no
this is the wild west like we have no
idea what this manifests itself into
which is exciting
yeah yeah cool thank you so much for
having me
you